Speaker 1: Let's now go from talking about the
guy who wants to be president to the gal who
wants to be his vice president. We know how great
it went for John McCain to select Sarah Palin to
be his vice presidential running mate in 2008. So
naturally, the next step is for Trump to choose
Marjorie Taylor GREENE in 2024. Right. And indeed,
it has been suspected that she wants the job.
It has now been confirmed that Marjorie Taylor
GREENE does indeed want that job. We suspected
that the lunatic extremist conspiracy theorist
Marjorie Taylor GREENE was desperate to be Donald
Trump's vice presidential running mate. Now
we know it. And this is the continued Jerry
Springer ification of the Republican Party.
Marjorie Taylor. GREENE Dangerous conspiracy
theories and horrible statements obviously have
no place in the White House. They have no place
within a heartbeat of the presidency. But
when it is the modern Republican Party,
I don't assume that it's out of the question. NBC
News reports Marjorie Taylor GREENE aims to be
Trump's VP pick in 2024. Former Trump aide Steve
Bannon has spoken with GREENE and says, quote,
She sees herself on the short list for Trump's
VP. Now, whether she is on Trump's short list is
a completely separate question to people who have
spoken to GREENE say that she is trying to be the
VP. This is no shrinking violet. She's ambitious.
She's not shy about that, nor should she be,
said Steve Bannon. She sees herself on the short
list for Trump's VP, paraphrasing Cokie Roberts,
When Marjorie Taylor GREENE looks in the mirror,
she sees a potential president smiling back. A
second source who has been advising GREENE said,
quote, Her whole vision is to be vice president.
The source is tied to Trump and spoke on the
condition of anonymity. Said he also believes
GREENE would be on Trump's short list. The
goal is at the heart of Greene's recent effort
to rebrand herself as a politician who can
stand astride the divide between the party's
hardliner hard liners and its establishment
wing. So understand that this sheds major light
onto why Marjorie Taylor GREENE, after saying
for years she is not part of the Republican
establishment, it explains why she criticized
those who dissented from supporting. McCarthy
for speaker just weeks ago and joined those who
support Kevin McCarthy. She sees an opportunity.
And you know what? Marjorie Taylor GREENE is out
of her mind, but she's not. Stupid in the sense
that she recognizes now that Republicans are going
to control now that the Republicans do control
the House. She can be on one side or the other.
She can be one of the detractors of Republicans
within the House. Or she can be on the side of we
are now in power. We are legitimate people to be
taken seriously rather than the clowns that many
correctly see us to be. And so she has decided to
put herself on the side of the speakership and
of the establishment Republican Party. Clearly,
this was all to try to make herself more palatable
and to be taken more seriously. To potentially
be Donald Trump's running mate. Now she is out of
her mind, she said. The 2018 California wildfires.
Maybe there was a Jewish space laser that was a
factor. She has alluded to the 911 attacks being a
false flag event in the sense that she said she's
not really sure that a plane did hit the Pentagon.
She has talked about shootings potentially being
hoaxes or hoax like. She, of course, is one of
the biggest promulgates of the obvious to any sane
person lie that the 2020 election was not really
won by Joe Biden, but rather stolen by Biden and
actually won by Trump. This is what we might refer
to as a dumpster fire of an elected official.
And not only does she want to be Trump's VP,
there are people who would vote for her to be the
vice president. That's maybe the most frightening
thing. Now, admittedly, it may be a relatively
small portion of the Republican Party. I don't
know. We're going to find out. I am sure that she
is being vetted among with others to potentially
be potentially be Trump's VP. But thinking ahead,
many steps Trump as president was humiliating
enough for the United States. Okay. If somehow
Marjorie Taylor GREENE became the vice president,
it would be even more embarrassing. Let's hope it
doesn't happen because it would also endanger our
national security in all sorts of different ways.
But Marjorie Taylor GREENE, we knew it, and it's
now been confirmed she wants to be Trump's VP.
We'll have more on all of these stories on our
Instagram. Find us on Instagram by searching David
Pakman Show. Find me on Instagram at David Pakman.